escorted by the pakistani military we're
taken to the talking border with
afghanistan
along the dusty and winding kaiba pass
there is nervousness across this region
about what will happen now there are new
rulers in kabul
at the crossing that change of god is a
surreal sight
more mad max than immigration
taliban fighters
some with knuckle dusters manning this
international boundary
the pakistani government has over the
last few years erected a security fence
along what was once a porous border
it hopes it will protect the country
from the turmoil next door
aid agencies say the humanitarian
situation inside afghanistan is
worsening
every day and the country desperately
needs international assistance but with
the taliban in control
funneling aid in is extremely difficult
now
islamabad has ordered even tighter
controls along the border
officials here say the country simply
cannot cope with another refugee crisis
foreign secretary dominic graab also
visited the area taking a helicopter
where he was briefed by the pakistani
military the uk is still trying to get
people out of afghanistan
what it will rely on is the taliban to
live up to their assurances to continue
to allow safe passage from afghanistan
back to the uk for uh not just british
nationals but also the afghans that
worked for us whether that's our land
routes including potentially pakistan uh
or via the airport in kabbalah
and this is the man the uk may have to
go through to get things done in
afghanistan
muller abdul ghani bharada is expected
to be the new leader of the government
[Music]
things have changed though since the
extremists last ran the show
their faces not covered these women
protest defiantly for equal
[Music]
rights the question is despite promises
of inclusivity
will the taliban tolerate this at all
once they've cemented their grip on the
country
alex rossi sky news